NEXT TIME?
WE'LL BE JOINED BY AN AVIATION
CONSULTANT AND FORMER MANAGER AT
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
>>> THE DEATH TOLL IN NEW YORK'S
ERIE COUNTY HAS RISEN TO 39
PEOPLE AFTER THE BLIZZARD WE SAW
IN RECENT DAYS.
THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE IS WARNING
THAT SADLY MORE DEATHS ARE
EXPECTED AS CREWS ARE CLEARING
ROADS, CONDUCTING WELLNESS
CHECKS OF PEOPLE STRANDED OR
STUCK IN THEIR HOME.
AND NOW APOLOGIZING AFTER HE
CRITICIZED THE MAYOR OF BUFFALO
FOR HIS STORM RESPONSE SAYING
THAT HIS EMOTIONS GOT THE BEST
OF HIM.
ATHENA JONES IS LIVE IN BUFFALO
THIS MORNING.
WHAT ARE WE HEARING FROM THE
OFFICIALS AS THEY ARE STARTING
TO CLEAR UP THE ROADS BEHIND YOU
AND REALLY ASSESS THE DAMAGE
FROM THIS STORM?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
KAITLAN.
A LOT OF THE ROADS HAVE BEEN
CLEARED AS YOU CAN SEE.
THE TEMPERATURE HAS ALREADY
RISEN.
TRASH PICK UP RESUMING TODAY.
CITY HALL OPENED YESTERDAY ALONG
WITH THE COURTHOUSE, SO THINGS
GETTING BACK TO NORMAL BUT NOT
FOR THE FAMILIES WHO MAY BE
MISSING LOVED ONES STILL.
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER HAS
CONFIRMED 39 DEAD BUT THE ERIE
COUNTY EXECUTIVE SAID THAT
NUMBER IS ALMOST CERTAIN TO RISE
BECAUSE THERE WERE SEVERAL OTHER
BODIES FOUND, WHETHER IN A HOUSE
OR OUTSIDE.
THEY NEED TO BE AUTOPSIED AND
REVIEWED BY THE MEDICAL EXAMINER
TO DETERMINE IF THEY WERE DEATHS
CAUSED BY THE BLIZZARD.
YOU MENTIONED HIM APOLOGIZING
HIM TO THE MAYOR OF BUFFALO FOR
CRITICIZING HIM FOR A LACK OF
ENGAGEMENT.
HE SAID THAT CRITICISM WAS
MISPLACED, LOST HIS FOCUSED AND
APOLOGIZED.
BUT THE DEATH TOLL IS ONE THING
WE'RE WATCHING TODAY.
>> AS WE'RE MONITORING THAT, ONE
THING THAT STOOD OUT IS THE
STORIES WE HAVE HEARD.
WE HAD SOMEONE ON TALKING ABOUT
HOW SHE HELPED JOEY WHITE STUCK
IN A SNOW BANK.
WE'RE HEARING SO MANY OF THESE
STORIES, HAVE ANY OF THEM STOOD
OUT TO YOU?
>> Reporter: SURE.
THEY CALL THIS THE CITY OF GOOD
NEIGHBORS AND THIS IS WHAT THIS
STORY REPRESENTS.
A MECHANIC, JAY WHITE WAS STUCK
IN THE SNOW AT ONE POINT, TRYING
TO DRIVE HIS CAR TO HELP A
FRIEND, COULDN'T MAKE IT THERE.
HE HAD AN ADVENTURE ON THE WAY,
A WOMAN WHO RAN OUT OF GAS, SHE
JOINED HIS TRUCK, THEY TOOK
TURNS SLEEPING THAT NIGHT.
EARLIER HE TRIED TO GO TO AT
LEAST 10 HOUSES OFFERING UP TO
$500 TO LET HIM SLEEP ON THE
FLOOR, ALL OF THEM SAID I'M
SORRY, TURNED HIM AWAY.
SO HE RETURNED TO HIS VEHICLE,
HE AND ANOTHER WOMAN SLEPT IN
THEIR VEHICLE AND EVENTUALLY
THEY DECIDED TO BREAK INTO A
NEARBY SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY KNEW
IT WOULD HAVE HEAT AND
BATHROOMS.
AND THEN HE WENT OUT INTO THE
SCHOOL'S PARKING LOT AND FOUND A
BUNCH OF PARKED CARS PEOPLE
STRANDED IN THE VEHICLES SO HE
SAID COME INTO THE SCHOOL I
BROKE INTO AND THAT'S WHERE THEY
SPENT THE REST OF THE BLIZZARD
UNTIL ABOUT EVENING OF CHRISTMAS
DAY.
AND HE SAID, YOU KNOW, IF ONE OF
THOSE HOUSES HAD LET ME IN, I
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE SO MANY
LIVES.
HE SAID THAT AGES RANGED FROM
ABOUT 26 YEARS OLD TO AROUND 73.
AND HE LEFT A NOTE IN THE END AT
THE SCHOOL AND HE SAID, TO
WHOMEVER IT MAY CONCERN, I'M
TERRIBLY SORRY ABOUT BREAKING
THE SCHOOL WINDOW AND BREAKING
THE KITCHEN GOT STUCK 8:00 P.M.
FRIDAY, SLEPT IN MY TRUCK WITH
TWO STRANGERS TRYING NOT TO DIE.
THERE WERE SEVEN ELDERLY PEOPLE
ALSO STUCK I HAD TO DO IT TO
SAVE EVERYONE AND GET THEM
SHELTER AND FOOD AND BATHROOM.
AND POLICE SAID LATER THESE
PEOPLE WERE STUCK IN AREAS THEY
COULD NOT BE REACHED.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
CALLS THAT WENT UNANSWERED SO
THIS MECHANIC TOOK IT UPON
HIMSELF TO NOT ONLY SAVE HIM